- I, you know, I like meat
and I like the tastes of savory meats,
but there's something about jerky
that just makes me wanna vomit.
- The road trip jerky taste test
- With The Try Guys.
- We've been up since 5am.
We got four hours to kill in the car.
Let's eat some jerky.
- Jack Link's Turkey Jerky.
- Quality tradition and
the spirit of adventure
has been their way of
life for over 100 years.
That's a lot of years.
- It's weird lookin'.
- It smells like dog food.
- Mmm. Mmm.
- It tastes like you'd expect.
- But the flavor, pretty delicious.
- It reminds me of Thanksgiving dinner
where you're eating the
little burnt pieces of turkey.
- If this was a hot male
celeb, Turkey Jerky would be
Chris Pratt cause he's like,
totally doin' what he should be
as an action movie star,
but he's just better for you.
- I like it.
- Wild Bill's Bacon Jerky.
- [Voiceover] It's bodacious.
- No we're not.
- [Voiceover] We're suppose to do it.
- This guy is very confusing.
- It's bo-delicious.
That's nice.
Oh, bodacios.
- Bacon jerky sounds incredible.
- Ooo, I love how much fat's on this.
- Oh god, it smells so pungent.
- Best snack this side of the Rio Grande.
- That's not the bacon I expected.
- If Beggin' Strips tasted like this,
I would fuckin' eat Beggin' Strips.
- I don't hate it.
- Its hot male celeb equivalent
is Channing Tatum.
because it's kind of rich in fat,
but it's always tasty.
- This was bodacious.
- The Original Slim Jim
- I'm turnin, am I turnin' left or right?
- Step into a Slim Jim.
Eat me.
- Snap into not step into.
- Okay.
- It looks like a dehydrated dick.
- It's hairy on the end.
- Mechanically separated chicken.
Ooo, paprika.
- [Voiceover] Are we just gonna gloss over
the mechanically separated chicken?
- We have so far.
- Oh, it's so juicy.
- For a food that's described as a stick,
it's a pretty decent food.
- C minus.
- Slim Jims are like Sam Smith.
They're gooey in the middle.
There's something interesting about them,
but you can't stop listening
or eating it, you know?
- 7-Eleven Original Beef Jerky.
- This is great cause
when I think quality food,
I think 7-Eleven Select.
- It's a little bit purple.
Purple's a fun color for jerky.
- Looks like a quilt.
- A little tougher.
- Oh man, this crumbles in my mouth.
- This is an exercise.
- Not as good as the other ones,
but still delicious.
- Aaahhhhh.
- This one's, by far, the worst.
- 7-Eleven, what have you done?
- I got, I got nothin' for this.
It just makes me sad.
- My hot male celeb, Vin Diesel.
It's tough, it's tough,
it's a little leathery,
but everyone, everyone can buy into it.
- [Voiceover] No, he
did not say Vin Diesel
was the 7-Eleven.
- [Voiceover] Vin Diesel is high praise.
- Apparently, everyone
else in the Try Guys
is obsessed with Vin Diesel.
- [Voiceover] I love Vin Diesel!
- Jack Link's Original Matador
- $1.29, I don't trust anything
that costs less than $2.
- This one's sweatier than the other one.
- Uhhh, it's sopping wet.
Too wet, too wet.
- Bursting with flavor.
- Very odd, but still, but weirdly sexy.
- Hint of spice.
- This is a horrible experience.
- This is the Benedict Cumberbatch.
There's something just slightly
off about him,
but in the best way possible.
- I'm gonna throw up.
I'm gonna throw up, I'm gonna throw up.
- No you're not, really?
- We've, we've made a terrible mistake.
- Maybe it wasn't the best idea
to open six packages of cured meat
in a car of men who have
been sweating all day.
But, tomato toe-mat-toe,
you live with your decisions
and you smile throughout.
See you next time on
we're in a car eating garbage.
BuzzFeed presents